when Highwood does any kind of movie or
TV show about counterterrorism but
spying they tend to have Jack Bauer
doing something dramatic if James Bond
do something dramatic they have Carrie
Mathison doing something emotional and
dramatic you had information about an
attack but it's like one person in one
danger is placed in one powerful thing
and that's not the way the world
actually works in reality the u.s.
relies on a web of intelligence sharing
agreements with other countries
the best-known of these is the five eyes
agreement between the US Canada the
United Kingdom New Zealand and Australia
but the u.s. also gets Intel from
countries that are geographically closer
to terrorism hotspots Jordan Saudi
Arabia the Emirates Turkey Israel these
countries often have agents undercover
inside groups like Isis they get
something valuable they trust us with it
that could be an intercept of a phone
call drone imagery showing somebody that
one country is looking for it could be a
plot that was the case in 2010 when
intelligence sharing between the US and
six other countries stopped an al Qaeda
plot to bomb two cargo planes and route
to the US and what makes it all work
what kind of like grease if that
relationship is trust they believe that
they tell us a secret that's safe one of
the most important of these intelligence
sharing relationships is the one between
the United States and the Israelis so
when the Israelis found out about a
specific threat from Isis that they plan
to use laptops to bomb airplanes the New
York Times reports that the Israeli
shared that information with the US with
the understanding it would stay secret
but the Washington Post reports that
President Trump shared that information
with the Russian Foreign Minister during
his visit to the US and in doing so he
seriously jeopardized that relationship
with the Israelis to understand why you
have to back up a little bit and look at
what Russia is doing in Syria president
Trump has said Russia is a key ally in
the fight against Isis there I say it's
better to get along with Russia than not
and if Russia helps us in the fight
against Isis which is a major fight and
Islamic terrorism all over the world
right major fight that's a good thing
promised them in Syria
Russia's goal is not to fight Isis
Russia schools to protect Bashar al
Assad Russia fight Isis only insofar as
it sees Isis as a threat
Charlo side and one of Russia's main
partners in this objective is Iran who
the Israelis considered to be their
greatest threat in the region
the greatest danger that we face as the
hatred for the Jewish people and the
Jewish state comes from the east it
comes from Iran for months Israeli spies
have expressed this fear that any
intelligence they share with the US
could end up via Russia in the hands of
the Iranians and now those fears have
been confirmed if they no longer trust
the CIA that means that the plot that
might have otherwise been stopped or
disrupted potentially happens because
they don't trust that if they tell to us
it won't go to an enemy of theirs and
it's not just Israel now other allies
may become wary of sharing intelligence
with the US without trust these
intelligence sharing relationships break
down and without these relationships
it's harder for US intelligence
officials to do the very thing Trump
says he wants to accomplish defeat Isis
and disrupt terror plots
[Music]
you
you